[Music]
they say a journey is measured in
moments not miles
and most importantly you have to figure
out who you are and why you are here
and I think once you figure that out
life is just an expression
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know how to put words on unlike
my feeling but it's true that for like
ocean I can't do without it just I feel
dizzy when it's not here
[Music]
when I put my first feet in the water I
just forgot everything
the coach of the family and I just want
to serve Him and enjoy it actually
[Music]
[Music]
just having Jen by my side during both
ups and downs Springs and lightness
about life
Bianca inspired me really like she's
always here for me and I will always be
here for her every year the season
starts in Australia
[Music]
[Music]
traveling for me is so important because
make you open your mind so much on
everything I feel so lucky to travel
with a friend and share moments like
this because life is about sharing too
life begins where your comfort zone ends
and I feel like the most I've ever
learned or the most I've ever
experienced was world traveling
in surfing male and female have a
different way of expressing what they
know on a wave femininity and surfing is
a beautiful thing and performance and
masculinity in surfing and salsa and I
don't think it should be compared
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
it's you
I just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shoo
[Music]
last year I qualified for the W City
everything becomes possible not for me
[Music]
everything good comes a desire to make
it lost the ocean is my escape but in
the same way it is my arena it is
expectation and it's a place where I
have to perform
[Music]
I get knocked out in the second round
it's so much different when you're in
anything you can as a speaker just say
your composure and your legs feel dizzy
pretty stressing to get in the water and
know that you can lose
[Music]
gave me
yeah your face
Oh
cuz
love you
Oh
[Music]
face stop me
away
[Music]
[Applause]
seeing her on the podium was so amazing
and when it's all finished like all the
crazy contests and all these people I
just looked by my side and we can be on
can we just go have a serve and we just
realized that it's what we love to do
consume
it's your life it doesn't matter
actually if we know if we lose it's not
about that it's just about what we love
to do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you
[Music]